what is up guys welcome to another video
brought to you by statistically
challenged today we are going to be
looking at secret slash uncommon money
making methods an old school runescape
that can make over 500k an hour so let's
get right to it
for our first method we are going to be
baking potatoes so what you're gonna
want to do is get your ass to the grand
exchange and buy some potatoes after you
bought the desired amount of potatoes
which you're gonna want to do is get
yourself to a cooking range now there
are a lot of cooking ranges in the game
but the one I'm going to be using for
this video is gonna be the one in
edgeville now you're just gonna take out
your potatoes from your bank take them
to the cooking range you will cook these
without failure every single time on a
range it will not work on a fire so make
sure you are cooking them at a cooking
range each time you cook the potato you
will receive a baked potato and 15
cooked in the experience after you're
done cooking a full inventory return to
the bank and repeat the same process
place all 28 baked potatoes on the grand
exchange I would get around 8.4 K we're
making around 7.5 K profit every single
inventory so this method should bring in
400 to 500 K per hour depending on how
afk or active you are although this is a
very 8k method so it's pretty nice
autumn method to
for method to get yourself to the Nome
stronghold we are gonna be making
blueberry specials once you hear climb
up the ladder and run directly east here
you're gonna see an NPC called heckle
flinch
ensue are at heckle punch you're gonna
want to right-click them and trade them
and you're gonna want to buy one brandy
one gin one vodka equal leaves two
oranges three lemons one lime along with
a cocktail glass a cocktail shaker and a
knight now that you have all these items
in your inventory you're just gonna want
to right-click your cocktail shaker and
select the mixed cocktail and then
select the D Blair berry special now
you're gonna use your knife on the lemon
to dice the 11 to get lemon chunks these
are knife on the orange to dice the
orange to get orange chunks and then use
your knife on the line to get sliced
lime and then all you're gonna do is
left click pour mix special you'll get
150 cooking experience and you will get
a blueberry special if you can do this
fast you can make a blueberry special in
roughly 10 seconds and every blueberry
special you make is worth 5.7 K so this
can make you over 1mill an hour if you
are active enough and do it properly I'm
just gonna show you that this can be
done quite fast it doesn't take too long
you can actually make one in you know
like under 20 seconds if you know
exactly what to buy and you will after
you do this a couple times and every
time you're making one of these you are
actually profiting around 5.6 K I
believe they're worth five point seven K
in the GE and we're gonna go sell them
right now as you can see we successfully
sold the 538 specials for around five
point six five K each which is insane
profit because we are barely spending a
hundred GP for the supplies so get good
at this and you can make over 1 million
our automatic three
so from f23
all you're gonna need again is some
starting cash you're gonna go to the
grand exchange and buy some blue tea Hut
buy as many as you can
I'm gonna buy a hundred for the sake of
this video once you have your D hike
you're gonna want to go to alkyd the
best way to get there is grab a ring of
dueling and to teleport to the alcove do
Lavina then once you're not grid you're
gonna want to head to the bank once
you're at the bank just take out your
blue dragon hides and with some cash in
your inventory run to the Tana which is
located by the t-shirt icon then what
you're gonna wanna do is just right
click the blue d hide and select all now
you will have all your blue d hides
turned into blue dragon leather you're
gonna want to bank them and repeat this
process I'm now done tanning my lager
and I'm back at the grand exchange as
you can see from the history we spend
two hundred and twenty five point four K
buying all the leathers and we just
turned one hundred of those into tan
leathers and we're going to sell them
now after selling them as you can see we
made around 20k just selling back the
one hundred letters that we tend the
great thing about this is that only took
me about four minutes to ten a hundred
leathers which is just around four trips
from the bank to the Tanner so for
tanning booth jihad you're looking at
around 600 K per hour assuming that
every 5 minutes you can do a hundred
leathers and make around 20k profit so
that about wraps it up guys I hope you
enjoyed these three secrets such unknown
moneymakers and I hope you can use them
to make some Bank yourself if you guys
want more and if you guys enjoyed this
vid and want more please leave a like
comment and subscribe and I'll see you
the next vid thank you all for watching
and have a great day
you